tu es dans le même cycle politique un
état répressif des élites porté vers la
corruption vers le détournement de
deniers publics
une volonté de confisquer les attributs
de l'ensemble de la souveraineté c'est
laden de la classe politique qui à qui
la place du colon jusqu'à présent le
coup d'état du 5 septembre n'a pas
surpris est-ce que c'était prévisible
pour vous également tu était tout à fait
prévisible puis deux années même avec
monsieur alpha condé deux pays étaient
dans une crise profonde à la fin de son
second mandat il a cherché par tous les
moyens y compris des moyens tout à fait
inadmissible à se maintenir au pouvoir
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité à de la journée au
sommaire de ce jeudi 11 novembre
[Musique]
les tensions à la frontière entre la
biélorussie et la pologne sont toujours
des milliers de migrants bloqués là dans
des conditions humanitaires désastreuses
nous le verrons dans un instant sur le
front diplomatique d'un côté knicks et
de l'autre varsovie et bruxelles se
renvoient la balle face à de possibles
nouvelles sanctions européennes
le président biélorusse menace de couper
l'approvisionnement à de gaz vers
l'europe le conseil de sécurité de l'onu
tient une réunion d'urgence aujourd'hui
la russie demande aux européens de
renouer le dialogue
c'est une première à la présence des
états unis au forum mondial pour la paix
un coup d'envoi aujourd'hui et un tapis
rouge pour kamala harris la
vice-présidente américano côté à des
manuels macron alors la hache de guerre
après la faire des sous marins est elle
enterrée est ce le retour de washington
à la table de la coopération
multilatérale nous verrons cela au menu
notamment la crise sanitaire les enjeux
numériques et de super sécurité la
capitale accueille une trentaine de
chefs d'état et de gouvernement
un forum mondial pour la paix sur fond
de reprise de l'épidémie de kobe de 19
en france et en europe sous la menace
d'une cinquième vague a lors de son
allocution mardi soir emmanuel macron a
annoncé l'arrivée de nouveaux
traitements anti corrida la fin de
l'année où en est-on à quoi s'attendre
et nouvel art n'a dit le président en
français s'agit-il d'une alternative à
la vaccination on en débattra ce soir
enfin nous parlerons économie avec un
zoom sur les bourses mondiales elles
vont de records en records notamment
paris avec un cac40 à plus de 7000
points plus hauts historiques aussi à à
wall street comment expliquer une telle
euphorie des bourses ne sont elles pas
déconnectée de l'économie réelle
éléments de réponse tout à l'heure dans
l'édito échos de jacques sapir
[Musique]
cela fait plusieurs semaines que des
milliers de migrants sont bloqués à la
frontière entre la biélorussie et la
pologne il espère à entrer sur le
territoire de l'union européenne et des
réfugiés en provenance du moyen orient
et d'afrique prise au piège du bras de
fer diplomatique entre minsk et
bruxelles elles vivent dans des
conditions très difficiles illustration
sur place avec notre envoyé spécial
antoine claireaux qui s'est rendu dans
le campement de grodno en biélorussie
après trois jours de vie sur place le
camp se structure de plus en plus en
plus des tentes on voit apparaître
maintenant des huttes et des cabanes de
plus en plus élaborées pour construire
ces cabanes mais aussi pour le bois de
chauffage les migrants se servent dans
les forêts alentour principalement en
bois de bouleau et de sapins le corps en
question s'étend sur plusieurs centaines
de mètres de longueur et sur une
vingtaine de mètres de largeur entre le
chemin où je me trouve et la clôture de
fils de fer barbelés qui marque la
frontière avec la pologne lavez sur
place est très précaire beaucoup dorment
à même le sol à proximité des nombreux
feux de camp unique source de chaleur
dans ces conditions difficiles les plus
fragiles voient leur état de santé se
dégrader rapidement
les autorités biélorusses distribuer aux
et nourriture principalement des
saucisses des pommes de terre et des
pommes plusieurs citernes comme celles
ci ont été installés le long du
campement où les migrants viennent se
servir en eau potable et y faire
une toilette sommaire la composition du
camp évolue également au début il y
avait principalement des kurdes irakiens
mais les derniers arrivés viennent
d'autres pays du moyen orient et même
d'afrique j'ai beaucoup marché j'ai fait
tout presque tout le contenu de la
frontière
c'était pénible mais je suis quand même
arrivé on allume du feu il fait froid on
n'a pas de tente jeudi vendus l'union
européenne puisque c'est c
c'est à cause d'eux que nous nous nous
retrouvons là le pouvoir résoudre ce
problème pour que nous puissions aussi
retrouver nos vies retrouvez la
meilleure vie que tout temps tout est
recherche ce qui peut surprendre aussi
c'est le nombre de familles beaucoup de
femmes et d'enfants voire de très jeunes
enfants à noter également la forte
présence militaire côté biélorusse pour
surveiller le camp pour empêcher les
débordements et bien entendu côté
polonais pour empêcher les migrants de
franchir la clôture ce campement grossit
et se structure chaque jour davantage
tous ces gens sont déterminés à rester
ici coûte que coûte jusqu'à ce qu'une
solution soit trouvée et ce malgré les
privations malgré le froid malgré la
neige qui va faire son apparition d'ici
quelques jours et ce avec cet objectif
en tête gagner l'union européenne un
rêve pour beaucoup à la fois proche et
inaccessible le représentant onusien du
haut commissariat pour les réfugiés
s'est rendu à la frontière côté
biélorusse il fait point sur l'aide
apportée aux réfugiés alerte face au
risque d'une situation qui s'éternise
écoutez le
la situation est très catastrophique est
dans un jour elle le sera encore plus je
pense par conséquent nous devons faire
quelque chose
nous avons déjà commencé à fournir une
aide humanitaire par le biais de la
croix rouge nous allons continuer
pendant quelques jours ce que nous ne
voulons pas c'est qu'un quand se forme
de façon permanente ici et alors que le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu se réunit
en urgence aujourd'hui à à new york
vladimir poutine et angela merkel ont de
nouveau échangé par téléphone tout à
l'heure a le président russe appelle
l'union européenne au rétablissement à
des contacts avec la biélorussie
on voit les dernières déclarations
diplomatiques avec adrien fonteneau
les jours se suivent et se ressemblent
dans le conflit migratoire pollono
biélorusse pour résoudre le problème en
gueule à merkel et vladimir poutine se
sont entretenus par téléphone ce jeudi
le président russe a exhorté l'europe à
renouer le dialogue avec la biélorussie
la chancelière allemande à elle insisté
sur l'aspect sécuritaire dans la région
ainsi que dans l'est de l'ukraine de
nice monastir ski ministre ukrainien de
l'intérieur à d'ailleurs annoncé le
déploiement de 8500 militaires aux
frontières avec la biélorussie et la
pologne autre point abordé par angela
merkel l'instrumentalisation des
réfugiés par alexandre loukachenko une
situation humanitaire que la france
perçoit comme une attaque ce n'est pas
une crise migratoire c'est une attaque
migratoire est ce qu'on va laisser
l'europe être déstabilisée par quelques
milliers de migrants si on dit tout le
monde est le bienvenu ce ne serait pas
sérieux et cela encouragerait
loukachenko a continué il est évident
que si la russie n'est pas une part du
problème elle est au moins une partie de
la solution puisque la dépendance de la
biélorussie à moscou est de plus en plus
forte même son de cloche côté union
européenne ou alexandre loukachenko est
pointé du doigt à l'occasion du conseil
des affaires étrangères ce lundi à
bruxelles les vingt-sept devraient
étendre et renforcer leurs sanctions
contre la biélorussie et face aux
menaces européennes la biélorussie
entend bien répondre avec fermeté
s'il nous impose de nouvelles sanctions
nous devons répondre nous chauffons
l'europe et il menace de fermer la
frontière
et qu'est ce qu'il se passerait si nous
coupions le gaz naturel qui va là bas je
conseillerais donc aux dirigeants
polonais aux lituaniens et aux autres
écervelée de réfléchir avant de parler
alors que le conseil de sécurité de
l'onu se penche ce jeudi sur le dossier
biélorusse d'autres discussions sont
prévues les ministres des affaires
étrangères et de la défense français et
russes doivent se réunir vendredi matin
à paris
et pour revenir sur cette crise à la
frontière entre la pologne et la
biélorussie
on retrouve tout de suite nos invités
[Musique]
avec nous ce soir françois pour les
matières journaliste spécialiste des
institutions européennes et jean paul
garraud un député européen du
rassemblement national bonsoir messieurs
merci d'être avec nous en direct alors
comment est-ce qu'on en est arrivé là
d'abord françois paul et mathis
je crois qu'on en est arrivé là tout
simplement parce que il y à une rivalité
qui est évidente maintenant entre d'une
part la biélorussie est derrière la
russie et l'union européenne suit bien
sûr aux sanctions qui ont été décrétées
par l'union européenne notamment
vis-à-vis de la biélorussie après les
élections ratées entre guillemets 2001
et après notamment la l'assaisonnement
d'un l'arraisonnement d'un avion pour
capturer un opposant ces sanctions
effectivement on mise en colère
effectivement la biélorussie qui essaye
aujourd'hui d'utiliser des moyens
j'allais dire assez cynique des moyens
de force pour effectivement faire plier
l'union européenne et la faire accepter
finalement de gêner ces migrants qui
arrivent mais ces migrants qui arrivent
ils sont pas arrivé tout seul ils sont
arrivés grâce à des agences très
organisés qui ont organisé des départs
depuis la zone n'irait irako syrienne
vers la biélorussie
et puis tous ces migrants sont arrivés
ont été emmenés vers la frontière vers
la pologne et puis une fois qu'ils y
sont ils ne pas pu revenir en arrière
quand on glisse françois paul et
mathilde agence bien organisés à quoi
faites-vous allusion précisément je fais
allusion des agences bien organisés
qu'elles soient russes ou qu'elle soit
biélorusse qui sont bien sûr pas
organiser directement par le
gouvernement pas forcément mais les
gouvernements ni russe ni biélorusse
tour besoin et l'organiser ils ont pour
cela des agences qui font le travail et
finalement il bienveillants vis-à-vis
ces agences qui elle achemine tous ces
migrants depuis la zone irako syrienne
vers la frontière polonaise mais le
problème c'est que il pousse tous ces
migrants vers la frontière polonaise ils
émettent en otage système a
systématiquement en otages d'une
situation qui est invraisemblable qui
est d'un cynisme épouvantable car
effectivement on a rarement vu une
guerre de ce type il s'agit bien d'une
guerre mais d'une guerre qu'ils
n'utilisent pas des moyens militaires
des moyens arbez mais une guerre qui
utilisent des moyens humains dans des
conditions et dans des circonstances qui
sont plutôt intolérable alors bien sûr
cette situation elle a de quoi choquer
jean paul garraud votre lecture vous de
la situation
oui il ya bien sûr une lecture politique
une lecture humanitaire naturellement je
ne conteste en aucune façon par contre
ce que je souhaite dire ce qu'il ne faut
pas limiter cette question aux problèmes
politiques concernant la biélorussie
parce que ce serait trop simplifier les
choses la réalité est tout autre en
réalité on a un problème de crise'
grattoir général puisque je rappelle
quand même que depuis le début de
l'année
2021 il y à une augmentation
considérable de l'entraidé me grandes
lignes augmentation de 1700 % d'entre
elles émigrant clandestinement dans
l'espace européen dans l'union
européenne par les frontières orientale
de l'union européenne donc ce n'est pas
qu'une question biélorusse cette affaire
c'est une question beaucoup plus général
de crise libératoire en l'occurrence
d'agression migratoires pourquoi alors
bien sûr pourquoi il faut se poser la
question alors je ne conteste pas qu'il
y ait certaines normes de la part de la
biélorussie une volonté de rétorsion par
rapport à l'union européenne par rapport
aux sanctions qu'elle m'aime bien lire
au ici donc subi de la part de l'union
européenne c'est très vraisemblable oui
mais chez jean paul garraud votre
appréciation de de la position justement
de bruxelles face à sète à ces migrants
qui sont bloqués donc à la frontière
entre la pologne et la biélorussie
l'union européenne qui refuse de céder
et est votre appréciation
l'union européenne est en train de subir
le contrecoup d'une politique migratoire
qu'elle a toujours encouragé si vous
voulez madame la commissaire yves la
johnson comme vous l'écoutez ce serait
très bien d'ailleurs de de l'écouté plus
souvent d'une façon plus médiatisé c'est
véritablement une catastrophe telle
politique est une politique qui est
directement
pro-immigration liste mais
d'une façon très importante le 9
novembre dernier madame johnson
s'exprimer au parlement européen et en
disant justement que il fallait
encourager il fallait transformer en
gros les migrations illégales en
immigration légale parce que
malheureusement pour des raisons
financières un certain nombre de
migrants ne pouvait pas avoir accès aux
pacers donc elle a dit cela le 9
novembre
à une autre occasion elle s'est exprimée
ou jordan bardel à s'exprimer sur ces
sujets et bien pendant que jordan
bardella s'exprimer sur ces sujets
migratoire très important au parlement
européen madame johansson elle tricotait
le voyez ce que je veux dire donc cesser
vous avez une politique migratoire que
l'union européenne encourage sous des
prétextes démographique parce que nous
aurions besoin de la démographie
apportées par les migrants nous aurions
besoin aussi du travail que les migrants
vont effectuer dans notre pays tout ceci
est dit redit sans arrêt et donc
aujourd'hui on a créé h un peu le gaz et
l'union européenne refusent pour
l'instant d'ouvrir sa frontière on a
entendu le témoignage d'ailleurs d'une
femme venue du continent africain 1
recueillies par notre envoyé spécial on
l'a entendu tout à l'heure c'est à cause
de l'union européenne si nous sommes là
dit elle sur le sort des réfugiés les
conditions humanitaires on dénombre
d'ailleurs des arrestations des
refoulements qui pose question regard du
droit international
est-ce que la responsabilité de l'union
européenne est clairement engagée dans
cette crise humanitaire françois de
poulet mathis oui je crois qu'elle est
engagée pour quoi et là je reviens petit
peu sur ce qui vient d'être dit ce n'est
pas l'union européenne qui en tant que
telle cherche à ouvrir ses frontières
aux immigrés je crois que le problème
c'est que l'union européenne est en
situation d'échec de politique
migratoire sa politique migratoire elle
n'est pas fixée elle n'est pas cohérente
et donc le fait d'avoir d'absence
d'europe fait effectivement que il ya
une certaine forme de laxisme par
rapport à ce problème de l'immigration
sur lequel l'europe est dans
l'incapacité actuellement de s'organiser
pour gérer collectivement ce problème il
ya des contradictions absolument
épouvantable on voit par exemple qu'un
pays comme la pologne et c'est le comble
qui héberge l' agence frontex de
surveillance des frontières et bien que
la pologne refuse l'aide ou l'apport de
l' agence frontex à ses frontières ça
montre bien cette contradiction qui à la
fois on voudrait que l'europe fasse tout
mais à la fois on fait en sorte que
l'europe soit impuissante et les
nationalismes ressortent essais
nationalisme sont un frein épouvantable
à toute solution qui pourrait être une
solution concertée entre les différents
pays européens c'est là qu'est le
véritable problème alors on voit ces
réfugiés prise au piège d'un bras de fer
entre minsk d'une part à
varsovie et bruxelles justement jean
paul garraud l'allemagne fait appel à la
russie pour que moscou interviennent
dans cette crise la dîmière poutine le
président russe a appelé justement
l'union européenne à reprendre le
dialogue
avec la biélorussie que peut faire
moscou concrètement hormis conseillé aux
européens de discuter
que des siens mais difficile de dire ce
que peut faire la russie naturellement
j'ai d'autant plus que c'est pas dans ma
nature de dire aux autres pays et ce
qu'ils doivent eux faire je respecte la
souveraineté de tous ces pays je reviens
juste un instant en arrière parce qu'on
reprochait la polo ne pas faire de ne
pas disons faire signe à frontex et
pourquoi pourquoi la pologne ne le fait
pas tout simplement parce que la fronde
30 textes c'est pas du tout des
gardes-frontières contrairement à ce que
les gens peuvent croire frontex c'est
une agence en quelque sorte d'accueil
des migrants voilà est là actuellement
si vous voulez la pologne ne peut pas
faire appel à cette agence puisque cette
agence ne va pas du tout joué un rôle de
garde frontières je voudrais dire aussi
qu'il ya quand même 12 pays membres de
l'union européenne et pas des moindres r
si je puis dire l'autriche naturellement
la république tchèque la pologne bien
entendu la hongrie et d'autres qui ont
demandé à l'union européenne à la
commission européenne d'avoir des moyens
pour protéger leurs frontières je leurs
frontières extérieures à l'union
européenne je rappelle que je ne parle
pas des frontières intérieures sur
locales y ait des discussions je parle
des frontières extérieures moi j'ai
toujours entendu que à commencer
d'ailleurs par emmanuel macron qui a dit
qu'il fallait descendre les frontières
extérieures de l'europe nous sommes là
dans un débat sur les frontières
extérieures de l'europe et en
l'occurrence des frontières orientales
et bien l'union européenne s'en lave les
mains il ne veut pas donner les moyens à
ces pays
2 justement faire en sorte de pouvoir se
défendre
il ya juste le garant en
convient mais je ne m'aimais sur le
raisonnement pourrait résoudre ce
problème
d'un point de vue financier la
souveraineté de ces pays ne doit pas
être violées et je ne suis pas du tout
d'accord avec le fait que l'union
européenne puisse se voir une politique
en matière migratoire surtout pas parce
que si l'union européenne peut légiférer
en matière migratoire je peux vous
assurer qu'on va voir d'ailleurs avec le
pacte européen sur l'immigration et
l'asile qui doit être appliquée bientôt
on va avoir 60 à 70 on dénigrement qui
vont arriver sur notre évidemment sur
notre espace européen alors la
catastrophe humanitaire dont on parle on
va l'avoir ici on va la voir en france
parce qu'on ne pourra pas accueillir
toute la mesure de toute la misère du
monde c'est terrible d'autres l'ont dit
avant moi mais c'est la réalité donc la
politique de l'union européenne ne doit
pas être une politique qui favorise
toutes ces pompes aspirantes à
l'immigration on précipite c'est
malheureux parce qu'ils croient bien sûr
qu'ils vont être chez nous bien mieux
que chez eux et alors qu'on devrait
prendre toute une série de mesures avec
les pays en question les pays qui
envoient entre guillemets tous ses
matches et
j'en reviens à ma question parce que la
solution pour
résoudre justement cette crise urgente
elle et diplomatique actuellement j'en
reviens à ma question il ya une volonté
de la part de l'union européenne de
faire intervenir la russie est ce que la
solution c'est celle ci
écoutez que la russie interviennent sont
très bien pourquoi on se passerait de la
ville la russie naturellement la russie
d'une grande puissance ici elle peut
avoir de danse est dans cette affaire un
rôle qui puisse débloquer la situation
il faut bien sûr l'utiliser
naturellement et j'espère que
effectivement le forage sans avoir des
oeillères c'est le problème dans toute
cette affaire c'est que au niveau
européen et de l'idéologie de l'union
européenne souvent il ya justement des
oeillères françois poule et mathis alors
la biélorussie 1 qui menace de
couper l'approvisionnement en gaz
justement vers l'union européenne
il s'agit de fermer la vanne du gazoduc
yamal-europe qui est gérée par le géant
russe gazprom qui traverse quatre pays
on rappelle la biélorussie la pologne
l'allemagne mais
la russie également et surtout alors
justement est-ce que la biélorussie a
les moyens de ses ambitions est ce
qu'elle peut se permettre de passer à
l'acte je ne suis pas sûr que les que la
russie a les mots enfin que la
biélorussie a les moyens de ses
ambitions pourquoi parce que
l'approvisionnement en gaz de l'europe
c'est très important effectivement en
période de recrudescence des prix de
l'énergie c'est effectivement une menace
qui doit peser mais il faut savoir aussi
que pour la russie ce serait une menace
et la russie n'a probablement pas
intérêt du tout ap a provoqué une
couture de l'acheminement du gaz vers
l'europe et donc je pense finalement que
je crois pas trop à de solutions clés y
est peut-être des coupures partielles ou
quelques quelques menaces partiel mais
de couper définitivement à un réseau
aussi important que yamal europe c'est
absolument invraisemblable et la russie
ne l'accepterai pas c'est pour ça que je
ne crois pas beaucoup à cette solution
je crois qu'il y aura une solution la
solution vient du fait que comme il n'y
a par exemple entre la turquie le maroc
et l'europe il ya des accords pour
maintenir les réfugiés avant la
frontière vers l'union européenne il n'y
a pas de ce type d'accord avec la
biélorussie il faudra d'une certaine
manière arriver à un arrangement pour
qu'il y ait un accord effectivement pour
que
certains de ces immigrés puissent être
retenue ça fait partie des solutions
possibles mais de toute façon on ne peut
pas continuer à ignorer la réalité la
réalité c'est que les micros ignorent
les frontières nationales de l'europe
ils ne savent pas ce que c'est les
migrants niveau en dans l'union
européenne d'ailleurs la personne
africaine qui a été interviewé tout à
l'air de dire j'en veux à l'europe parce
que c'est l'europe qui doit répondre
c'est l'europe qui doit répondre et
c'est pas ni la pologne ni la france ni
l'allemagne c'est l'europe que les gens
attendent et cette europe
malheureusement aujourd'hui c'est vrai
elle est un peu absente c'est ce qui
fait sa faiblesse alors les critiques on
peut faire contre l'europe sont réelles
elles sont réelles du fait de l'absence
de concertation et de l'absence de
coordination c'est ça le véritable
problème c'est pas qu'il faut moins
d'europe au contraire il faut plus
d'europe l'europe qui agite d'ailleurs
la menace de quelle sanction merci à
vous françois poulet mathis journalistes
spécialisés institutions européennes et
avoue jean paul garraud député européen
du rassemblement national
autre crise migratoire en tunisie le
pays n'hésitent pas à expulser à les
migrants arrivés sur son territoire vers
la libye l'onu a condamné tout à l'heure
l'expulsion arbitraire de dizaines
d'entre eux et de demandeurs d'asile à
les nations unies dénoncent également
leurs conditions de vie et sommes tunis
de respecter ses obligations en matière
de traitement des réfugiés ont fait le
point à tunis avec notre correspondant
bassam shetty
tunis dans le viseur de l'organisation
des nations unies et du haut
commissariat pour les réfugiés est
devenu le point de passage obligatoire
pour rejoindre l'europe la tunisie fait
face depuis quelques années à un flux
important de migrants africains qui
transitent par la libye dépassés par la
situation et dépourvu de cadre juridique
tunis n'a cessé ces derniers mois de
procéder à des expulsions parfois
violentes de ces migrants vers la libye
dans un communiqué cette rapporteur de
l'onu ont tiré la sonnette d'alarmé sur
les conditions de détention de ces
populations qui sont très souvent privés
d'eau de nourriture de soins médicaux
est exposé un réel danger de tortures
d'enlèvements et de violences sexuelles
écoutez nous sommes profondément
préoccupés par la sécurité la dignité
l'intégrité physique et les conditions
de vie des migrants en particulier des
femmes enceintes et des enfants qui sont
bloqués à la frontière tuniso libyenne
ces personnes sont soumises à des
violations de leurs droits en tunisie et
en libye à la lumière des rapports que
nous avons reçus sur l'augmentation du
traitement raciste et xénophobe des
migrants d'afrique subsaharienne à tunis
la société civile s'organise pour venir
en aide à ces déplacés de plus en plus
nombreux à s'installer dans le pays en
attendant de rejoindre de façon
clandestine les côtes italiennes elle
dénonce une précarisation des conditions
d'accueil de ces réfugiés est une
violation flagrante de leurs droits les
plus élémentaires pour honda ben amor
membres du forum économique et social
tunisien la tunisie doit se doter
rapidement d'une politique migratoire
éclaircie à ses relations avec l'union
européenne écoutez le
il ya une vraie absence de stratégie
nationale en matière immigration et une
absence totale de position notamment en
matière de soumission aux politiques
européennes et au chantage qu'exerce
l'union européenne en vue d'intensifier
les contrôles côté méditerranée de ce
fait la tunisie est devenue une
plateforme de filtrage des migrants sans
cadre juridique qui protège leurs droits
et sans moyens humains logistiques et
matériels pour préserver leur dignité je
pense que les organisations de la
société civile font un effort
considérable pour surveiller et
documenter les violations dont les
migrants sont victimes malheureusement
nos moyens financiers logistiques
demeurent très faibles et cette
situation dépasse les capacités des
organisations internationales et celle
de la société civile pour gérer au mieux
cette catastrophe humanitaire
bien que signataire de la convention de
genève relative aux réfugiés tunis ne
s'est toujours pas doté d'un cadre
juridique indispensable à son
application en 2021 sur les 6500
demandeurs d'asile que compte le pays
moins de 3000 ont pu obtenir le statut
de réfugié le forum de paris sur la paix
s'est ouvert un tout à l'heure une
quatrième édition inaugurée par à
emmanuel macron et kamala harris à la
vice-présidente américaine les états
unis qui n'avaient pas participé aux
premières éditions sont souvient donald
trump avait pris soin de boycotter le
rendez vous alors cette fois on se
demande si les états unis vont sceller
leur réengagement en matière de
coopération multilatérale une grande
conférence consacrée également à la
réduction à des fractures mondial on en
parle tout de suite avec notre reporter
nadège abderrazak
nadège bonsoir alors depuis est la
création du forum pour la paix ans en
2018 c'est donc la première fois que les
états unis y participent à quels sont
les enjeux de cette présence américaine
absolument la présence de la
vice-présidente américaine signe le
réengagement des états unis dans les
questions multilatérales
après quatre ans de boycott du forum de
paris sur la paix par le président
donald trump alors kamala harris était
aux côtés d' emmanuel macron tout à
l'heure pour l'inauguration de cette
4ème édition du forum sur la paix un
signe d'apaisement peut-être entre paris
et washington après le scandale et des
sous-marins kamala harris a pris la
parole en premier pour appeler à plus de
parité d'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes
est désolant
c'est un honneur d'être ici aujourd'hui
de rejoindre les leaders de ce monde et
de discuter d'une importante idée
l'égalité a été en
croire des experts plusieurs experts par
exemple suggère qu'il faudra des
décennies pour que les femmes obtiennent
une parité avec les hommes
oui et en tant que leader nous sommes
confrontés à ce challenge qui est
immense de taille est effrayant ims nfos
size and sky emmanuel macron s'est
exprimé juste après kamala harris le
chef d'état français a appelé un
multilatéralisme efficace on les écoute
un moment même où nous vivions
collectivement une crise inédite du
multilatéralisme
désaccord juste signé des remises en
cause
les organisations multilatérales
voyez certains de leurs membres éminents
s'éloigner et donc nous avons
collectivement essayer de bâtir de
nouvelles méthodes cherchait de nouveaux
acteurs bâtir un nouveau destin
collectif en étant plus efficaces
ensemble
et grâce à vous toutes et tous nous
avons tenu durant ces années
et je dois dire madame la vice
présidente que de savoir les états unis
d'amérique revenant pleinement dans le
club du multilatéralisme fut pour nous
tous une formidable nouvelle
est donc merci pour cela une trentaine
de chefs d'état et de gouvernement sont
attendus à cette quatrième édition du
forum sur la paix 2 paris qui se tient
jusqu'à samedi ici même à la grande
halle de la villette alors ce forum créé
en 2018 visant à instaurer un rendez
vous diplomatique à paris un peu comme
il se fait à davos en matière économique
ou encore à munich sur les enjeux à
sécuritaire pour cette édition en 2021
l'accent devrait être mis sur la
réduction des fractures à l'échelle de
la planète et parmi les autres sujets au
programme est la crise est liée aux
copies de 19 bien sûr la cyber sécurité
ou encore l'amélioration de la
solidarité entre les états
merci beaucoup à vous un adage
abderrazak pour toutes ces précisions
continue de parler de ce forum mondial
pour la paix avec notre invité drieu
godefridi docteur en philosophie
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors évidemment on
s'interroge sur les intérêts américains
l affaire des sous-marins déjà démontré
une volonté de peser face à la chine en
matière de coopération multilatérale est
ce que c'est cette même ambition qui
motive les états unis à paris
je pense que ce qui motive les états
unis à paris c'est essentiellement de
refaire dans la mesure du possible une
relation qualitative avec la france
puisque cette relation a été je dirais
considérablement endommagée à la page
sur le plan symbolique et sur le plan
économique avec la faire des sous marins
quant à savoir si ce forum en tant que
telle est donc la présence américaine
dans se forme à une réelle portée sur la
gestion des affaires internationales et
a fortiori sur la paix mondiale on peut
se montrer beaucoup plus sceptique je
dirais la france qui doit prendre
d'ailleurs la présidence de l'union
européenne en janvier prochain est-ce
que parmi les points de convergence il
faut aussi compter sur le soutien
américain à l'europe de la défense chara
emmanuel macron héros forcément de
l'otan
c'est à dire que la relation entre les
pays européens et les américains sur le
temps est une relation qui elles aussi
endommagées
de longues gagneuse et pas simplement
pendant le mandat de monsieur trump les
difficultés remontent à avant le mandat
de monsieur tron et se poursuit jusqu'à
nos jours la vraie difficulté principale
étant l'échec de la grande majorité des
états européens aujourd'hui en ce
compris et à commencer par l'allemagne a
consacré un budget suffisant au maintien
et à fortiori au développement d'une
force militaire qu'ils soient
suffisantes c'est là l'europe de la
défense repose depuis des années voire
des dizaines d'années sur une grande
illusion ce n'est pas parce que vous
mettez des forces qui sont insuffisantes
à vous les voulez vous voulez rassembler
que cela fait nécessairement une force
suffisante il y a un problème de
crédibilité européenne par rapport à
l'otan qui est d'abord et avant tout un
problème budgétaire
alors il ya d'autres enjeux lors de ce
forum deux ans de ce forum dans le
domaine numérique et la lutte contre la
cyber sécurité ce que là aussi on peut
parler de réels points de convergence à
face à la domination des grandes
plateformes numériques et les
cyber-menaces également
le votre question est très intéressant
parce qu'elle pose véritablement
l'intérêt et la question de l'intérêt de
ce type de forum est ce qu'on peut
sérieusement imaginer que lorsque vous
allez à la réunion d'un forum sur la
paix qui se saisit de questions aussi
vaste aussi multilatéral aussi complexe
est aussi fortement déterminé je dirais
par lord américain peut-on réellement
imaginer ou concevoir l'idée que ce
forum permettra les avancées
substantielles sur de telles questions
j'utilisais le mot de scepticisme tout à
l'heure à c'est particulièrement le cas
sur des questions comme comme celle là
je vais également souligné qu'il y a au
programme de ce forum d'autres questions
telles que l'intelligence artificielle
où la question des débris dans l'espace
sa veillée l'expression en français en
vieux français médiéval qui dit qui trop
embrasse mal étreint
alors justement sur la forme on voit ce
forum a beaucoup d'attraits
kamala harris sa présence à paris ce
n'est pas joe biden qui s'est déplacé
mais donc la vice-présidente américaine
qui jouit d'une aura internationale
d'une image positive emmanuel macron
sait aussi qu'ils aiment ce jeu de la
forme mais sur le fond réellement est ce
que on peut s'attendre à des choses
concrètes à l'issue de ce forum mondial
pour la paix je partage effectivement
tout ce que vous venez de dire ils ont
en particulier votre scepticisme sur le
fond je pense qu'il est il est illusoire
d'en attendre autre chose que les
prolégomènes à la possibilité d'un
accord sur un certain nombre de
questions ponctuelles telles que la
gestion des débris dans l'espace pour le
reste la présence de madame harris offre
effectivement à ce forum une portée
médiatique il n'aurait probablement pas
eu si elle avait été absente mais en
même temps qui est madaba russe elle est
la vice-présidente des etats-unis est là
aujourd'hui et je jouais aujourd'hui aux
états unis de 28% d'opinions favorables
ce qui est probablement le plus mauvais
scores de l'histoire de ce pays depuis
depuis sa fondation donc c'était les
mêmes une personne qui n'est pas
véritablement je donne en position de
pouvoir ou de force justement ça forum
mondial pour la paix il a été initié par
emmanuel macron sous le prisme
finalement macro nist on se dit que le
président français il a envie de
reprendre la main un petit peu côte est
des états unis après on en a parlé de la
faire des sous marins sur cette question
là qu'en pensez vous je pense que encore
une fois on ne peut que 80 des coques ce
que vous avez dit à monsieur macro et au
delà monsieur macron la france a été
totalement humiliés dans cette affaire
des sous marins maintenant la france
n'est pas en position pour avoir tourné
le dos je dirais qu'on partenaires
américain et donc il faut faire contre
mauvaise fortune bon corps et on a
effectivement ici un monsieur m'a
conquis tant parce que probable sur
vaqueront de devenir une sorte de deux
leaders de fait de leader virtuel de
l'union européenne avec le retrait de
wallemme merkel donc on a ici monsieur
mâcon qui se profilent comme il
effectivement à le faire comme une sorte
de leader naturel en europe est-ce qu'il
parviendra à maintenir cette posture
c'est ce que l'avenir c'est ce que
l'avenir nous dira une dernière question
qui concerne la crise sanitaire et la
couverture vaccinale à mondiale est ce
que les états unis se sentent
véritablement concernés par cette
fracture vaccinale nord-sud on sait
qu'il ya beaucoup de chefs d'état
africains présents à ce forum mondial
pour la paix s
question intéressante parce que les
américains n'en ont repris il peut sur
que même affectionne c'est-à-dire
donneur de leçons mais en même temps ils
se sentent compte que pendant la
première phase a de cette pandémie les
américains ont pris une règle les
anglais ont fait pareil qui était très
simple chaque vaccin a produit sur le
territoire américain sera attribuée à un
citoyen américain maintenant qu'il y à
une forte couverture vaccinale aux états
unis alors oui les américains
s'inquiètent de la couverture et à juste
titre évidemment parce que c'est de
l'intérêt de chacun de la couverture
vaccinale mondial et veut toujours
rapportés ce type de préoccupations
altruiste à la généalogie je dirais de
cette crise caractérisée dans sa
première phase par un très grand égoïsme
nationalisme américain dans l'ain
pendant que l'europe s'est montrée
depuis le départ beaucoup plus généreux
aux effectivement dans la possibilité
donnée à des vaccins fabriqués sur le
territoire européen d'être exportée
partout dans le monde merci beaucoup à
vous adrien goetz raid et je rappelle
que vous êtes docteur en philosophie
et alors que de nombreux chefs d'états
africains sont à paris le ministre
malien des affaires étrangères et lui à
moscou où il s'est entretenu avec son
homologue russe sergueï lavrov après le
retrait d'une partie de l'armée
française bamako et moscou confirment
leur volonté de poursuivre leur
coopération militaire les détails sur
place avec notre correspondante maylis
de stress
les chefs de la diplomatie russe a
déclaré que moscou poursuivrait sa
coopération militaire avec bamako en
fournissant des équipements et des
munitions aux troupes maliennes ainsi
qu'en formant leurs officiers concernant
la conclusion de contrats avec des
sociétés militaires privées sergueï
lavrov a rappelé qu'il incombait
gouvernement malien seul de prendre
cette décision ce qui concerne le
principe des compagnies privées des
compagnies militaires privées
nous n'avons ne vont pas de rapport avec
l'activité de ce type de structure de
structures créées par des citoyens
russes c'est elle qui conclut des
contrats
si ces contrats sont signés dans le
respect de la législation et
législations nationales je vois pas ce
qu'il ya de négatif qu'ils puissent
examiner ici le marché des services des
compagnies militaires privées
est développée
dans le domaine de la sécurité de la
défense
a été créée par les sociétés par les
pays occidentaux justement et les
leaders dans cette activité
avec des dizaines de milliers d'hommes
ont été créés par les américains par
les britanniques et pas les français qui
ont une douzaine d'entreprises qui
agissent un peu partout dans l'impasse
mme en afrique et
même beaucoup plus près du territoire de
la fédération de russie à ce sujet le
ministre malien des affaires étrangères
a évoqué une campagne de dénigrement
menée contre les autorités maliennes ont
crié maintenant pour ce qui concerne la
question spécifique
delà de la société de sécurité privée à
laquelle vous avez fait référence
nous avons eu aussi les échanges directs
avec nos homologues français sur cette
question et mêmes ont admis qu' aucun
acte aucun contrat qui a été signé dans
ce cadre maintenant il est question de
juger le mali sur la base d' intentions
que les autorités maliennes peuvent
avoir ou sur la base de rumeurs et
d'articles de presse qui sont
commandités ici et là sur lequel on n'a
pas vraiment à répondre mais je peux
vous dire aujourd'hui qui n'a absolument
rien mais ceci s'inscrit aussi dans le
cadre d'une campagne de dénigrement des
autorités maliennes pour pouvoir
vraiment nous mettre à mal avec nos
voisins avec la communauté
internationale
mais ce qui est important à retenir
c'est que la relation entre le mali et
la russie c'était une relation d'état à
état et le mali ne permettra à aucun
état ni à aucune institution de lui dire
avec qui elle peut traiter le ministre
malien rap et que la préoccupation
majeure du mali restait d'assurer
l'intégrité de son territoire sans
sous-traiter la sécurité à cette fin un
abdoulaye diop estime normal que bamako
cherche à diversifier ses partenaires et
deux ministres ont également évoqué la
coopération qui se développe entre leurs
pays dans des secteurs comme l'énergie
l'agriculture l'exploration des sols
internet ainsi que l'éducation
est diplomate c'est toujours le
président chinois lui met en garde
contre un climat de guerre froide en
asie pacifique en filigrane les tensions
autour de taiwan déclaration ce matin de
jean ping à la proche du sommet virtuel
avec son homologue américain joe biden
et cela alors que pékin et washington
ont réussit pourtant à se mettre
d'accord hier soir à à la coop 26 à
glasgow on voit cela avec mathilde de
romagne un
accord surprise entre les deux pays qui
polluent le plus au monde deux jours
avant la fin de la conférence
internationale sur le climat la chine et
les états unis ont fait une déclaration
commune et s'engage contre le
réchauffement climatique
pékin et washington disent avoir mis de
côté leurs divergences face à l'urgence
de la situation
la chine et les états unis ont plus de
points communs que de divergences en ce
qui concerne le changement climatique et
les deux partis dispose d'un grand
potentiel de coopération
il reste encore deux jours avant la
conclusion de la conférence de glasgow
sur le changement climatique et nous
espérons que cette déclaration commune
contribuera son succès
cette déclaration fait état de cet
effort de coopération de l'impératif de
coopérer elle déclare spécifiquement et
identifie la nécessité d'accélérer la
transition vers une économie mondiale de
zéro émissions nettes ensuite elles
s'engagent à mener une série d'actions
importantes n'ont pas à long terme non
pas dans un avenir lointain mais dès
maintenant
l'accord restent flous pour l'instant
mais les deux premiers émetteurs
mondiaux de gaz à effet de serre
promettent je cite de prendre des
mesures renforcées pour relever les
ambitions pendant les années 2020 mais
aussi de limiter le réchauffement
climatique à moins de 2 degrés par
rapport à l'ère préindustrielle voir un
degré et demi pékin et washington
réaffirment aussi leur attachement aux
objectifs de l'accord de paris rien de
très précis donc mais le geste est
saluée par le secrétaire général des
nations unies je salue l'accord
d'aujourd'hui entre la chine et les
états unis pour travailler ensemble pour
prendre des mesures plus ambitieuses
pour le climat pendant cette décennie
s'attaquer à la crise climatique
requiert une collaboration et une
solidarité internationale et c'est un
pas important pour aller dans la bonne
direction
cet accord entre la chine et les états
unis sur le climat est inédit mais reste
bien en dessous des attentes des pays
touchés par la crise climatique
selon l'onu le monde se trouvent
toujours sur une trajectoire
catastrophique de réchauffement de 2,7
degrés d'ici la fin du siècle
la tennis temps au bord de
l'effondrement économique un
avertissement du ministre pakistanais
des affaires étrangères à l'ouverture
d'une rencontre avec un des diplomates
américains chênois russe à islamabad
selon le pakistan il faut que la
communauté internationale roland son
soutien financier elle doit aussi
relancé à son aide humanitaire au pays
de toute urgence afghanistan dont les
fonds ont été gelés par des donateurs
occidentaux depuis la prise à deux
contrôles des talibans l'afghanistan
l'un des pays les plus touchés par les
mines antipersonnel comme la syrie et
les victimes sont en augmentation
partout dans le monde en cause la
pandémie qui selon un dernier rapport a
poussé plusieurs pays à interrompre leur
programme de sensibilisation aux dangers
des mines et les enfants sont
particulièrement touchées par ce fléau
les explications c'est en images
regardez
[Musique]
décidément un agenda international
chargé pour à emmanuel macron demain se
tient une conférence internationale sur
la libye à paris à le président réunit
plusieurs responsables de pays concernés
par la crise libyenne l'enjeu est de
taille le pays est plongé dans le chaos
depuis une décennie et parmi ces enjeux
s'assurer que la présidentielle du 24
décembre aura bien le tout comme les
élections législatives un mois plus tard
on voit cela avec david khalifa
mettre fin à dix ans de chaos depuis la
chute de mouammar kadhafi et tourner la
page d'un conflit qui s'est
internationalisé voilà les objectifs de
la prochaine élection présidentielle en
décembre prochain la première au
suffrage universel depuis que la libye
est indépendante ce malgré un
cessez-le-feu voté il ya plus d'un an le
pays peine à toujours s'unir avec à des
parties est et ouest qui continuent à se
déchirer il ya d'abord le parlement de
tobrouk présidée par haguy la salle et
qui continue à faire cavalier seul ils
s'opposent au gouvernement provisoire
implanté à tripoli est dirigé par le
premier ministre abdelhamid débat en
témoigne la prise de position de ce même
parlement qui a ratifié sans vote une
loi électorale pour accorder le droit
militaire de se présenter aux élections
afin de favoriser son candidat le
maréchal khalifa haftar ajoutez à ça le
conseil présidentiel dirigé par mohammed
ameen fille le cp mise en place en
février par un processus politique
parrainé par l'onu est destinée à
soutenir le gouvernement ces deux
instances sont censés préparer les
élections générales dans un cadre
pacifique mais c'est en fait tout le
contraire
quand lundi blanc l'autre noir dernier
couac en date la suspension de la
ministre des affaires étrangères
nadja allons bouche assortie d'une
interdiction de quitter le territoire
une triangulaire des forces politiques
s'est instauré et chacune entend tirer
son épingle du jeu la nomination le
limogeage la suspension la mise en
examen d'un membre de l'exécutif relève
des prérogatives exclusives du premier
ministre c'est dans ce contexte
politique pour le moins tendue que se
tient en france cette conférence
internationale en soutien à la libye
l'objectif est clair tout faire pour que
ces tensions s'apaisent et que les
élections se tiennent en bonne et due
forme mais la tâche s'annonce plus que
compliquée pour l'elysée les élections
sont à portée de main un mouvement fort
est à l'oeuvre en libye pour qu'elle se
tienne il y va de la stabilité du pays
mais des spoilers sont en embuscade ils
essaient de faire dérailler le processus
il faut donc rendre le processus
électoral incontestable et irréversible
des différends internes amplifié par la
multiplication d'ingérence étrangère
dans les affaires libyennes la libye est
un pays riche en pétrole de nombreux
mercenaires russes du groupe privé à
wagner dont le kremlin a démenti tout
lien mais également des éléments turc
tchadiens et soudanais sont encore sur
le sol libyen il serait vain mille selon
les chiffres de l'onu une présence
militaire qui déstabilise le pays car
chacune de ces milices veulent tirer
profit de l'instabilité politique en
libye les faire partir ne sera pas une
mince affaire malgré les divers
avertissements de louer nu mais aussi de
l'union européenne youssef critiquent
nos coachs unity
vous avez créé une opportunité de
reconstruire votre pays mais il ya une
condition préalable tous les mercenaires
et les troupes étrangères doivent
quitter le pays la mise en oeuvre de
l'accord de cessez-le-feu et le respect
de l'embargo des nations unies sur les
armes seront également crû sur dans ce
processus
will also be shown in dix huit mois plus
tard nous en sommes au même point ou
presque la présence étrangère est une
véritable épine dans le pied et les
factions libyennes l'ont bien compris
malgré ça à l'espoir demeure le dépôt
des candidatures pour ces élections
présidentielle et législatives s'est
ouvert lundi un peu moins de 3 millions
de libyens sur environ 7 millions
d'habitants se sont inscrits pour voter
ils ont deux semaines pour retirer leur
carte d'électeur dans les quelques 2000
centres de vote répartis dans le pays
signe d'un véritable désir démocratique
pour cette population traumatisée par
des années conflit et on va faire le
point sur cette conférence
internationale à venir demain concernant
la libye avec vous blanchemaison vous
êtes expert en relations internationales
ah bon soir alors qu'ils sont les enjeux
de cette réunion l'enjeu principal pour
les pays qui sont autour de la table
demain à cette conférence internationale
est évidemment d'éviter que la
transition dont on vient de parler ne
dérape et pour s'assurer que l'élection
présidentielle aura bien lieu à la date
prévue le 24 décembre élections
législatives qui doit être prévu à la
qui était prévue à la même date a été
finalement reporté d'un mois et pour
cela il faut également que la conférence
acquiert la certitude que tous les
acteurs de la sphère les bielles
respectons les résultats des votes qu'il
s'agisse de la présidentielle ou qu'il
s'agisse des législatives et que
par conséquent ensuite il n'y aura pas
de reprise des combats ça n'est pas
évident parce qu'en réalité il n'ya pas
consensus sur le schéma et on le voit
bien puisque l'assemblée nationale qui
siège à tobrouk a partie liée avec le
maréchal haftar et fait tout pour que le
match à la star soit élu président est
en réalité c'est sans doute pour cela
que l'on a découplé l'élection
législative de l'élection présidentielle
on l'a retardé d'un mois je pense que
l'une des craintes c'est que ça soit
encore différé beaucoup plus de façon à
ce que si haftar était élu eh bien il
est du temps pour pouvoir manoeuvrer et
instaurer un véritable régime
présidentiel mais pas le seul candidat
et parmi les candidats il y aura
peut-être le premier ministre qui n'est
pas là apparemment demain - qu'il arrive
par surprise mais il n'a pas confirmé sa
venue et puis il y aura l'un des fils de
kadhafi qui vient se rappeler au bon
souvenir de la population libyenne en
jouant la carte de la stabilité en
disant que finalement
l'époque du colonel kadhafi c'était
l'époque de l'instabilité en libye
donc on est loin de compte pour une
sortie harmonieuse de cette période de
transition juste à propos des élections
est ce que les conditions sont réunies
pour que les délais soient finalement
respecter les délais annoncés alors
formellement oui mais il faut évidemment
que le
gouvernement que le maréchal afar qui
contrôlent la partie là toute la partie
est du pays s'engage d'une part à
respecter le code électoral à ce que le
vote soit libre ce qui n'est pas de
pression sur les votants à ce que le
dépouillement soient convenablement fait
à skis et les observateurs étrangers
bien entendu et comme cette ce
gouvernement de la transition a été dans
le fond l'oeuvre de l'onu il est clair
qu'il faut que l'onu s'implique dans
l'organisation des élections et que
probablement eh bien il vaut mieux y
aller il faut faire ces élections sinon
ce ne sera que reculer pour mieux sauter
et probablement aussi ça décrédibilisera
tout processus de transition qui a été
organisé à grand peine au cours des deux
dernières années
justement demain à propos de la
sécurisation de ces futures élections à
venir vous parler de l'envoi
probablement d'observateurs
internationaux est ce que demain ce sera
une question qui va être abordé à y aura
un engagement de la communauté
internationale des acteurs présents
demain ça risque là d'un tout petit peu
surréaliste si vous permettez parce que
le premier ministre ne sera probablement
pas là le représentant de la libye sera
le président du conseil présidentiel qui
avait été déviée dans le processus de
transition organisée par l'onu
c'est-à-dire que soixante quinze
personnalités importantes de la libye
ont désigné le premier ministre et les
trois membres de ce conseil présidentiel
et c'est le président de ce conseil
présidentiel qui sera présent demain
mais évidemment par définition les
autres candidats ne seront pas là les
candidats ne seront pas là il n'a
d'ailleurs pas être là alors les grandes
puissances et les puissances voisines de
la libye vont s'exprimer vont s'exprimer
peut-être pour aider la libye à sortir
de cette transition dans de bonnes
conditions peut-être aussi pour protéger
leurs propres intérêts parce que comme
on l'a dit dans votre sujet il y avait
une condition aussi pour la tenue de
cette élection qui était que toutes les
troupes et autres mercenaires étrangers
s'en aille ils ne sont pas partis c'est
votre sujet qu'il a dit il en reste
beaucoup et évidemment ils vont jouer en
fonction de des instructions que leur
donneront leur parent que ce soit la
turquie où que ce soit d'autres pays et
les conditions sont particulièrement
difficile mais je crois qu'il faut quand
même y aller et il faut quand même faire
ces élections prendre le risque de faire
ces élections sinon ce sera la situation
sera probablement encore pire avec sk
les pays voisins qui vont participer à
cette conférence est pas si l'algérie
sera représentée vais les tensions avec
paris paris dont qui organise cette
conférence
sur la libye qu'est ce qu'on peut dire
sur les médiations en cours pour
résoudre le conflit libyen tel est le
poids de la france des rallyes terre
majeur l'algérie sera représentée par
son ministre des affaires étrangères
comme le maroc comme beaucoup d'autres
pays mais il ya évidemment des poids
lourds qui se déplacent par exemple le
président 6 6 2 l'egypte sera sera est
physiquement présent et
madame
comme anna cabana harris sera également
là
le miz affaires étrangères russe sergueï
lavrov sera là et par conséquent il y
aura effectivement des discussions mais
est ce que ces discussions permettront
d'aboutir à une solution consensuelle
qui puisse convenir aux différentes
factions syrienne ça n'est pas sûr la
présidence est coprésidé par trois pays
européens c'est un peu inhabituel la
france l'italie et l'allemagne qui ont
les petits sont les pays qui ont le plus
d'intérêt si vous voulez dans cette
affaire dans une solution de cette
affaire mais aussi toujours à la
présidence le nu et la libye elle-même
c'est-à-dire le président du conseil
présidentiel alors ça sera difficile je
pense que c'est l'onu qui a la plus
grande marge de manoeuvre pour négocier
puisqu'il avait réussi à mettre ces
autorités de transition en place il y a
un peu plus de huit mois donc l'onu est
bien placé peut-être pour essayer de
négocier mais une journée c'est très
court et probablement que assez peu pour
être fait sauf la confirmation des dates
pour ces élections le 24 décembre pour
l'élection présidentielle et un mois
plus tard pour les élections
législatives merci beaucoup à vous pour
à cette analyse claude blanchou mais son
fond
dans quelques instants nous parlerons de
la reprise de l'épidémie de kobe de 19
en france et en europe et des nouveaux
traitements sur le marché nous ferons
également un zoom sur les bourses
mondiales qui se porte particulièrement
bien c'est ce que nous expliquera
jacques sapir dans son édito échos a
tout de suite sur leur défense
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter ils
étaient ni sur la liste des morts ni sur
la bbc insu réalité hopitalisés il était
nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane et en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
pourquoi la guinée reste engluée dans
cette spirale de coups d'état depuis
l'indépendance jusqu'à présent on était
dans le même cycle politique un état
répressif des élites porté vers la
corruption vers les détournements de
deniers publics
une volonté de confisquer les attributs
de l'ensemble de la souveraineté c'est
laden de la classe politique qui à qui
la place du colon jusqu'à présent le
coup d'état du 5 septembre n'a pas
surpris est-ce que c'était prévisible
pour vous également tu était tout à fait
prévisible puis deux années même avec
monsieur alpha condé deux pays étaient
dans une crise profonde à la fin de son
second mandat il a cherché par tous les
moyens y compris de moyens tout à fait
inadmissible à se maintenir au pouvoir
[Musique]
le maintien de l'ordre une doctrine qui
est à la fois saluée dans le monde on
entend souvent parler d'excellence
française elle est aussi critiquée ces
dernières années quand on observe le
maintien de l'ordre en france au cours
du 20e siècle et début du 21e il ya
extrêmement peu de victimes même si mort
au maintien de l'ordre et une
catastrophe est tout à fait l'europe on
a vu des personnes gravement blessées on
a entendu aussi le terme violences
policières ce débat sur les violences
policières ce qu'il a toujours existé où
il a toujours existé ou la première
grande manifestation parisienne du 6
février 34 on a même pu craindre la
disparition de la toute jeune garde
républicaine au mitan la presse s'était
déchaînée sur ce qu'était réellement le
noyau dur du dispositif de maintien
d'ordre à l'époque
de coeur des femmes est plus fragile que
celui des hommes en france c'est 200
femmes par jour qui décèdent de maladies
cardio cérébrovasculaires c'est à dire
ses choeurs cerveau artères et c'est une
véritable urgence épidémiologique parce
que c'est l'hygiène de vie qui a fait
celui des maladies cardiovasculaires des
femmes première cause de mortalité six
fois plus que le cancer du sein par
exemple il ya toujours trois fois plus
importante chez les hommes que chez les
femmes mais ce qui nous alertent nous
c'est la progression du nombre de femmes
jeunes hospitalisés pour infarctus vous
expliquez que ça n'arrive pas par hasard
c'est une maladie qui est évitable dans
huit cas sur dix est évitable ça veut
dire que l'hygiène de vie c'est notre
facteur de risque numéro un on a plutôt
un système de soins qui était accès
fléché sur le traitement de la maladie
soupçon diagnostic et le traitement et
non pas sur la prévention et on est dans
un système très curatif 1 c'est
essentiel d'avoir l'information pour pas
subir
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire
emmanuel macron avait annoncé à
l'arrivée d'une nouvelle arme anti
qu'ovide mardi soir justement l' agence
européenne des médicaments via autorisé
la mise sur le marché de dos traitement
par anticorps où en est on à quoi
s'attendre s'agit-il d'une alternative à
la vaccination on en débat ce soir
et puis nous parlerons économie avec un
zoom sur les bourses mondiales elles
vont de records en records notamment en
paris avec un cac40 à plus de 7000
points plus hauts historiques aussi à
wall street comment expliquer une telle
euphorie des bourses ne sont elles pas
déconnectée de l'économie réelle
éléments de réponse tout à l'heure dans
l'édito eco2 j'accepte
[Musique]
lors de son allocution mardi soir
emmanuel macron a évoqué une nouvelle
arme contre le coc vie d'une façon pour
le président de mettre en avant l
arrivée de nouveaux traitements autre
que le vaccin pour lutter contre la
pandémie a justement l'agencé européenne
des médicaments vient d'approuver deux
traitements un suisse et un sud coréen a
les précisions c'est avec amaya
souplesse
c'est une nouvelle qui n'est pas passé
inaperçu lors de sa prise de parole
mardi le président de la république a
annoncé l'arrivée d'un traitement contre
le kobe 19 d'ici la fin de l'année
cinquante mille doses du médicament
maulnes upi ravir ont été commandées par
la france et devrait arriver fin
novembre ou début décembre selon olivier
ferrand
produit par le laboratoire américain
merck cette pilule réduirait de moitié
les symptômes liés au co vide la france
doit malgré tout attendre l'aval de
l'agencé européenne du médicament et de
la haute autorité de santé qui ont
accéléré l'examen du traitement la prise
de médicaments doit se faire dans les 48
à 72 heures suivant les premiers
symptômes
ce délai dépassé il est inefficace le
laboratoire américain pfizer a également
annoncé développer un traitement contre
le virus qui serait efficace à 89% le
laboratoire souhaite fournir des
résultats le plus rapidement possible à
l'agencé américaine du médicament
ces traitements antiviraux ont
l'avantagé de pouvoir être pris chez soi
mais représente un certain coût entre
1000 et 2000 euros pour chaque comprimé
astrazeneca est également en train de
travailler sur un cocktail d'anticorps
contre le coc vide des essais qui
pourrait mener à de nouveaux traitements
dans les mois à venir le mall du pire à
vire est autorisé depuis le 5 novembre
au royaume uni qui devient le premier
pays à commercialiser un traitement par
voie orale le régulateur a approuvé de
son côté ce jeudi de traitement par
anticorps de laboratoire suisse et nord
coréen les premiers médicaments contre
le virus autorisée au sein de l'union
européenne qui marque une nouvelle étape
dans la lutte contre le coc vie 19
et tout de suite place à notre
décryptage avec nos invités
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler frédéric avenel
et directeur du service des urgences de
l'hôpital avicenne de bobigny et denis
millet co président de la fédération des
syndicats pharmaceutiques de france
bonsoir à vous ah merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france alors c'est vrai le
président de la république qui l'a
annoncé lors de son allocution mardi en
plus c'est vrai de la troisième dose dès
le 15 décembre pour les plus de 65 ans
troisième dose de vaccin de nouveaux
traitements qui doivent arriver à la fin
de l'année en france il ya un antiviral
le module pirs à wihr qui est développé
par le laboratoire merck pilule qu'est
ce qu'on s'est concrètement sur cette
pilule d'abord qui est déjà utilisée aux
et au royaume uni et sur son efficacité
sur le co vide frédéric a donné
écoutez c'est le développé par le
laboratoire merck qui à l'origine
étaient les gènes molécules en fait
design et pour pour la grippe c'est un
nucléosides c'est si vous voulez une
certaine nouveauté dans le traitement
pour le coc vite parce que c'est un
antiviral directe c'est-à-dire qui va
inhiber ou diminuer la réplication
virale du sein score 2 en
substituant à nucléosides par ce
médicament et en trompant si vous voulez
la réplication virale ce qui est tout à
fait nouveau et ce qui nous laisse
beaucoup d'espoir c'est que d'abord
c'est un médicament qui se croient par
la bouche donc très facilement
transporter très facilement
administrable par la bouche on n'a pas
besoin de perfusions intraveineuses on
n'a pas besoin d'hospitaliser le patient
mais aussi c'est le premier médicament
qui va voir une action directement
antiviral alors qu'elle est actuellement
aux traitements efficaces sont soit
préventif soin à base d'anticorps
monoclonaux donc pour nous et au regard
de du communiqué de presse un immense
espoir qui doit bien sûr être confirmée
par les par les parties et les
publications scientifiques qui vont
pouvoir nous donner un petit peu le
rapport bénéfice risque en regardant un
petit peu les effets secondaires mais
aussi les bénéfices liés à ce médicament
alors il y a aussi d'autres traitements
qui ont été homologués le médicament
suisse le rhône après ve est un
médicament sud coréen le raid
d'anneville maps pas facile à prononcer
ces deux traitements ont justement été
approuvé aujourd'hui même par l' agence
européenne des médicaments
on sait aussi que pfizer astrazeneca
développe aussi des traitements avant de
parler justement de ces traitements
précisément de leurs spécificités denis
millet on a l'impression quand même que
ça s'accélère
au niveau de l'arrivée de ces
médicaments anti qu'ovide est ce que
c'est votre sentiment aussi comment
l'expliquer mais on explique que ça fait
deux ans qu'on est on est dans le camp
des beach on explique aussi parce que
les médicaments qu'il est déjà en
préparation le professeur vient d'en
parler et alors on est on est très très
peu si on était en train de discuter de
la manière dont c'est le maul des
fidèles puis ravir va arriver sur le
marché
je pense que l'inquiétude c'est qu'il ya
assez peu on a compté 50 mille doses
actuellement on détecte douze mille
nouveaux cas par jour en gros on a cas
on a quatre jours de stocks donc il faut
il faut relativiser ces produits sont
récents il faut pas négliger les gestes
de prévention pour autant parce qu'on a
un médicament qu'il faut continuer à
prendre le risque d'attraper la maladie
herman médicaments sont là sont pas
trois effets secondaires on a très peu
de recul on en aa allongé revendeur n'a
pas vu encore les les données qui vont
nous permettre de savoir quel est le
bénéfice risque donc logiquement que
c'est un espoir supplémentaire c'est
quelque chose de bien ils arrivent ils
étaient déjà sur le marché c'est ce
qu'on pourrait être en préparation
j'ai très bien qu'ils arrivent mais
attention c'est pas pour autant qu'il
faut se relâcher alors justement
expliqué nous la différence entre le
module pirs avis requête un antiviral
c'est ça et les deux médicaments les
deux traitements que j'ai citées
précédemment le rhône après v le raid un
ami l'imam qui sont des dés de
traitement par anticorps monoclonaux
les cliniquement je pense que je pense
que le professeur ne sera plus la même
deux mois et de médicaments sincèrement
aujourd'hui par l'annoncé de la
non à un travail sur le mobile à dire
depuis quelques jours mais là j'en étais
pas encore ancrées les arrivées très
clairement
frédéric à mener
alors écoutez le vol des pays jarry pire
à venir c'était une molécule qui va
inhiber la réplique et la réplication du
virus ativan empêcher le virus de se
multiplier à l'intérieur de la cellule
alors que les anticorps monoclonaux
c'est pas tout à fait nouveau ce sont
des anticorps qui vont si vous voulez
s'agripper à des à la protée s
puisqu'ils sont design et pour
inhiber la protéine s et réagir un petit
peu comme notre corps réagit contre
l'entrée de virus à dire on rajoute un
anticorps
parfaitement ciblées contre une protéine
du virus en espérant que ce virus soit
détruit grâce à ces anticorps le
problème c'est que ces anticorps
monoclonaux sa milice en milieu
hospitalier par voie intraveineuse alors
que les deux médicaments présentés par
le vent de la vente en mer ou riser sont
des antiviraux qui ont tout à fait un
autre mécanisme des antiviraux direct et
qui feront l'inventaire de sa demie
c'est par voie orale
simplement des comprimés combal ya une
question sur le télégramme daté france
qui s'affiche une question à d'agnès le
danois enfin c'est pas vraiment une
question c'est une affirmation nous
avons déjà des traitements efficaces
tels que l'ivermectine est libre au xi e
le rock in alors justement donné
milliers c'est vrai ce que vous pensez
que ça va relancer un peu là la
polémique sur sur les traitements l'
usage de ces médicaments
alors ça communique les forums par
contre je vois que maintenant fin du
débat des tranchées quoi que ce soit
l'hiver avec qui nous dit aussi que l on
fait peu de suffisamment de d'efficacité
et d'innocuité pour andré latine on les
aurait utilisés je crois qu'il faut
arrêter avec ce débat en disant que
bel essai je les ai pas raison
d'ailleurs puisque en plus des produits
des produits français c'était très bien
non ces produits arrivent ils n'ont pas
l'efficacité qu'on attendait ils ont un
certain nombre d'effets secondaires les
autres notre patte sans effet secondaire
c'est certain mais en tout cas ils ont
fait preuve d'efficacité avec des études
c'est le solide et démontrer ce qu'on
avait sur les liens avec les leaders
aucune étude qui était comme étant la
clé quoi et qui l'appliqué nombreuses
pour ne montrer leur efficacité voilà je
crois qu'il faut il faut ce débat alors
il y aura toujours les bras ou croco
vide les fans et pour hydro qui dit les
produire mexique voilà je pense que ça
va être très difficile de sortir un
certain nombre de gens de 7 de leurs
certitudes maintenant voilà neuf à
moitié un scientifique et certifie quand
on se base sur des études sérieuses qui
sont validées par pas par d'autres
scientifiques il faut pas qu'elle soit
juste et mises dans un dock qui avoue
dans un coin voilà auquel il a remis les
documents qui certifient casse ouais on
compare close
d'ailleurs denis est ce qu on sait qu'il
ya cinquante mille doses on l'a dit tout
à l'heure de du médicament mot nul peut
ravir qui ont été commandées par la
france est ce que vous avez vous des
informations sur la commercialisation la
mise sur le marché de ce traitement à
votre niveau
travailler la mise sur le marché en feu
24 h / des demandes spécifiques de
2,2 d'autres 92,2 de service qui sera
autorisé à le prescrire à ça va pas être
prescrit en ville de n'importe comment
et donc on aura des modalités de
commandes auprès d'un intermédiaire
codés via kies approvisionnera très
rapidement souvent un ou deux jours on
va voir le produit le plus rapidement
possible effectivement il faut il faut
admirer deux à trois jours ci dans la
détection du virus il faut aller vite on
en train de mettre en place la
technologie pour la voir le plus vite
aussi en train de s'entraîner gauthier
s'était toujours siècle
professeur à donner justement
l'agencé européenne du médicament doit
et la haute autorité de santé doivent
encore donner leur aval pour justement
autorisé le l' usage du mono le pire à
vire en france en tout cas dans une
grande partie de l'europe est ce que ce
sera avant la fin de l'année vous pensez
à qui va s'adresser aussi les 50000
pilule doses en tout cas qui ont été
commandés leur emprise break alors il
est vrai qu
à se mettre sous la dent que le
communiqué passe de l'avant port mer qui
est celui de fraser kursaal pour sa
pilule le dossier
aux autorités sanitaires je fais
remarquer que en angleterre il a déjà
abouti à une autorisation de mise sur le
marché pour le mener à bien
après
il faut qu'ils fassent rien à quoi vont
efficacité kim balance bénéfice risque
favorable promis et moi pour confirmer
les espoirs pouvaient être dans ce
médicament mais pour la sensible et on
n'a même pas la publication scientifique
qui nous permet de poser si vous voulez
les les effets secondaires versus les
effets bénéfiques de ce médicament en
tout cas ce qu'il a montré
diminué de 50% le taux d'hospitalisation
et ou de dessert dans une population de
patients qui étaient affectés par le
combi de 19 qui avait un facteur de
risque pour développer une forme grave
s'ils étaient administrées dans les
trois à cinq jours après le début des
symptômes d'octon qui doit indiquer ça
ce sera des personnes à risque je pense
qu'aux patients âgés aux patients qui
ont une comorbidité en tout début des
premiers symptômes à condition que la
caissière est affirmé qu' effectivement
son patient qui ont affecté par le
comité une autre question télégramme à
de mathieu les traitements sont la
solution depuis le début mais ça ne
rapporte pas assez un vaccin tous les
six mois pour le même résultat c'est
idéal financièrement sur l'aspect
financier justement de diminuer ses les
traitements c'est vrai
rapporte moins coûte plus cher peut-être
il écoute beaucoup plus terre là vous
l'avez évoqué on parle depuis quand est
allé voir milliers d'euros les
traitements we5 mettons j'ai pas le
temps parle de 1000 euros après tu mens
50000 euros voit on était à 50 millions
d'euros voyage 50cc échelle qui sont
très importants les vaccins étaient
entre une quinzaine de roms ou 15 à 20
europa où le roi des 30 euros avec
injection avec nous tout le tout la
technologie qui photo pour la jaquette
la population mais là on est sur des
traitements qui sont contents le millier
d'euros
les tories sont là les laboratoires
auront j'ai toujours le décret disney
moratoire sont là pour gagner de
l'argent mais sont là pour faire des
produits efficaces et qu'ils sont
surveillés et le droit puis ramenée à
raison il faudra qu'on vérifie avec les
études que les productions suffisamment
la valeur ce petit édifice crise soit
suffisamment valable puisque le match
parfait et dans quelle honte et je pense
qu'ils n'ont pas fait de manière
il en fait des dt raison comme si l'on
met ce marché c'est qu'ils ont peut
utiliser les dossiers qu'ils savent
qu'ils sont solides je pense qu'on
arrivera aux antilles
à suivre parce qu on aimerait bien les
voir à pas et on a un peu de données
qu'on n'a pas on a un communiqué le
laboratoire un peu juste pour se
prononcer on aime bien avoir le dossier
scientifique pour pouvoir étudier de
plus près ça va arriver des émissions de
ges et qui sera efficace
professeur anne est ce que ces
traitements finalement médicamenteux
sont représente une alternative
aux vaccins finalement et ça peut aussi
peut-être calmer les antilles vague de
pensée
sont pas comme l'a dit mon collègue pour
l'instant communiqué de presse et on a
comme une véritable analyse scientifique
de l'efficacité des médicaments on n'a
aucun recul quant à leurs effets
indésirables ou leurs effets secondaires
donc il est encore beaucoup trop tôt
pour vous dire que ces médicaments
pourraient remplacer le vaccin on est
dans deux stratégies différentes
la vaccination c'est un traitement
préventif et ici on nous propose des
médicaments qui sont un traitement
curatif donc ces deux approches sont
complémentaires et l'une va pas empêcher
l'autre par contre s'il s'avère que les
traitements curatifs sont extrêmement
efficaces évidemment il faudra
réanalyser notre politique doc signal
mais il ya aussi et vous l'avez signalé
un problème de coût entre un vaccin qui
coûte quelques dizaines d'euros et une
pilule qui coûterait plusieurs milliers
d'euros donc là aussi il y à il ya à
mettre dans la balance bénéfice risque
le coût de ces traitements donc je pense
que on va pas tirer des plans sur la
comète on est encore vraiment dans un
stade très précoce pour l'analyse de ces
traitements antiviraux curatif mais pour
nous il initia c'est un immense espoir
parce que on voit encore à l'heure
actuelle des gens mourir de lakovic 19
et on aimerait bien avoir des
médicaments qui pourraient arrêter mais
du coup très rapidement ce n'est pas un
peu rapide la mise sur le marché la des
traitements dont on vient de parler vu
le peu d'informations dont on dispose
denis millet très rapidement
on l'a bien dit pour l'instant surpoids
mission marchés n'ont pas l'autorisation
les marques ou le bol des pierres à vire
on attend il attend une autorisation en
angleterre on attend qu'il autorisation
en europe on voit le bélier en france
une fois qu'une famille au marché si
votre histoire a fait preuve son
efficacité après il faut relativiser les
vaccins on sait qu'elle est négatif sur
les mentalités de l'ordre départ 6 90%
un peu moins depuis le nouveau variant
mais là on ne parle que de 50 pourtant
important il faut que le pari est grave
pour les gens te dire je ne va-t-il pas
parce que jamais jamais le quément
protège d'une fois sur deux le risque
est important comme je pense qu'il vaut
mieux se vacciner avec avec une
protection aller même si on était à 80
cents
ensuite il malgré le vaccin on l'a on
aura une deuxième une deuxième chance
mais avec le traitement mais ne veut pas
ne te bat il est envisagé le traitement
qui arrive derrière on a un très gros
risque pour les personnes à risque merci
à vos données me et co président de la
fédération des syndicats pharmaceutiques
de france et merci à vous professeur
fabrican et directeur du service des
urgences de l'hôpital avicenne de
bobigny
après la france et ses plus de 11000
carrosse ans ailière record également
outre-rhin avec 50000 contamination en
24 heures une première depuis le début
de la pandémie et une reprise rapide qui
remet est les hôpitaux allemands sous
tension en cause selon les spécialistes
les 30 % des adultes non vaccinés mais
aussi elle est vaccinée de la première
heure dont l'immunité baisse le vice
chancelier allemand a s'est exprimé on
les écoute
pas la première chose est la plus
importante est que nous ne devons pas
relâcher nos efforts pour vacciner le
plus de citoyens possible
tout le monde n'est pas encore convaincu
que cela est bon pour eux et nous
devrions lancer une grande campagne
commune pour que des citoyens profitent
de cette opportunité de vaccination
nous devons évidemment maintenant se
faire tout notre possible pour nous
assurer que des millions de citoyens
reçoivent une dose de rappel que des
millions de citoyens se fassent vacciner
c'est la tâche des semaines et des mois
à venir
on termine avec un point sur l'économie
les bourses mondiales sur sont sur un
petit nuage
elle voit deux elle vole de record en
record notamment à paris avec un cac40 à
plus de 7000 points du jamais vu depuis
la bulle internet plus haut historique
aussi à wall street et au dessus des
indices boursiers sur le bitcoin alors
tout va t'il si bien sûr la planète
finance comment expliquer une telle
euphorie des bourses ne sont elles pas
déconnectée de l'économie réelle on en
parle tout de suite avec un l'économiste
jacques sapir dans l'édito rico
bonsoir à jacques alors l'euphorie
actuelle des bourses n'est-elle pas mal
scène alors que l'inflation monte que
les banques centrales se prépare à être
moins généreuse un oui on peut dire
effectivement qu'il y à un élément
malsain dans cette espèce d'envolée des
bourses on voit d'ailleurs que
l'inflation est aussi en train de monter
et généralement c'est deux choses qui ne
font pas spécialement bon ménage alors
oui vous avez raison les bourses se
prépare dans les différents pays a
adopté des programmes de réduction de
leurs achats voire de hausse des taux
d'intérêt mais au delà on peut se
demander si justement ces bourses ne
sont pas devenus elle-même les
prisonnières des marchés financiers
qu'elles sont censées justement
surveiller jacques est ce que les
bourses sont sont elles réellement le
foriic ah oui alors la samantha tout à
fait alors prenons le cas d'abord du cac
40 de la bourse de paris
il vient de passer à la fin de la
semaine dernière un record historique
les 7000 points qui n'avaient pas
atteint d'ailleurs à son plus haut en
2000 au moment de la bulle internet et
il continue encore aujourd'hui à être
au-dessus des 7000 points même chose
pour le dow jones à wall street à new
york le dow jones est au dessus de 36000
oui il est évident que actuellement nous
avons des plus hauts historiques pour
les bulls alors justement comment
l'expliquer à quoi c'est dû alors il ya
une explication d'ordre réel il faut le
savoir parce que bien sûr avec la crise
de l'aco vide certaines entreprises ont
tiré leur épingle du jeu les gaffes à un
google amazon etc ont fait de très gros
profits ont vu leurs dividendes
augmenter et donc il est normal que
leurs valorisations bon mais maintenant
il faut quand même dire que le reste de
la côte a quand même connu une une
anémie nettement plus compliquée que ce
qui s'est passé pour ces entreprises et
donc on voit bien que ce ne sont pas
simplement les éléments réels et qui
propulse les bourses à ses sauts mais en
réalité il y à bien la politique
des banques centrales les banques
centrales qui ont baissé très fortement
les taux d'intérêt qui n'arrêtent pas
d'injecter de l'argent dans l'économie
et ça évidemment ça provoque
l'équivalent d'une bulle boursière et
dans quelles proportions
alors ça c'est des proportions qui sont
assez considérables si on prend par
exemple le bilan de la banque centrale
européenne et il a augmenté de 24 % en
un an si vous voulez de de fin 2010 9 à
fin 2020 on a 24 % d'augmentation du
bilan si on prend maintenant les actifs
de ce qu'on appelle l'eurosystème c'est
à dire le réseau des banques centrales
de tous les pays et qui font partie de
la zone euro là c'est encore plus
spectaculaire
le ces actifs étaient de l'ordre de 2600
milliards d'euros en 2019 ils sont en
fin 2020 à
3500 milliards autrement dit un
accroissement de 40 % et si maintenant
on sort d'europe et qu'on regarde aux
états unis c'est encore plus fou si vous
voulez le bilan de la réserve fédérale
est pas fait de 4200 1 milliards à plus
de 7000 milliards autrement dit un
accroissement de 72% en moins de sept
mois donc oui il y a bien eu des
injections massives
du point de vue monétaire ces injections
justement massive de monnaie dans
l'économie est ce que c'est soutenable
alors c'est bien justement la raison
qu'on se pose et même chose par exemple
pour les taux d'intérêt alors
aujourd'hui on a déjà plusieurs banques
centrales qui ont annoncé leur volonté
de réduire leur politique de rachat des
titres de commencer à faire remonter les
taux d'intérêt nous avons la banque du
canada la banque centrale du canada ça
c'était à la fin du mois d'octobre
début novembre
c'est la réserve fédérale elle même qui
a annoncé qu'il y aurait probablement de
hausse de taux dans l'année 2022 et qui
a annoncé un resserrement
de ses rachats d'actions la banque
d'angleterre elle même a fait des
annonces dans ce sens et puis il ya déjà
des banques qui ont sauté le pas 1 il
faut quand même le dire en particulier
la banque de corée dans bref il y a
globalement aujourd'hui une forme de
tendance générale à la restriction
monétaire plus ou moins accéléré suivant
les zones et en europe 1 alors lequel
l'europe justement est intéressant parce
que on voit bien que l'europe étant un
petit peu en retard par rapport aux
états unis pour la reprise madame
christine lagarde lors de la dernière
réunion qui a eu lieu à la bce a
maintenu le discours en disant non il
est trop tôt pour parler d'un
resserrement est et elle a dit que
fondamentalement les taux ne bougerait
pas tant que l'inflation de manière
durable ne dépasserait pas l'objectif et
je rappelle que cet objectif est de 2%
sauf que sauf que l'inflation est déjà à
4 6% en allemagne à 3 % en moyenne dans
la zone euro donc ils sont un outil
comme l'allemagne et donc on voit bien
qu'il va y avoir des pressions d'ores et
déjà la semaine dernière et au début de
cette semaine la presse allemande a très
violemment attaqué madame lagarde
l'appelant madame d'inflation d'ailleurs
l'attaquant de manière pas très élégante
il faut le dire et donc on voit bien que
la banque centrale européenne ne pourra
pas maintenir sa politique elle sera
obligée et probablement ça sera annoncé
lors de la prochaine réunion qui doit
avoir lieu au début du mois de décembre
elle va être obligée d'annoncer beaucoup
plus vite des formes de restriction de
sa politique d'achats elle doit en
particulier décidé de la poursuite du
programme ppp le programme de rachat qui
était consécutif à la crise pandémique
normalement ce programme devait se
terminer au mois de mars 2022 il n'est
pas impossible qu'il se termine plus
vite que prévu et de ce point de vue là
on doit avoir vraiment les yeux rivés
sur l'inflation en allemagne alors est
ce que vous pensez jacques les banques
centrales
pourrait bientôt changer de stratégie
oui je pense que samantha que c'est
absolument inévitable agents pauvres
pour plusieurs raisons nous avons tout
d'abord cette inflation qui est peut
être transitoire mais combien d'années
mettons sous le mot transitoire il est
clair qu'elle se poursuivra en 2022 nous
avons les bulles d'actifs nous avons un
l'immobilier qui montent beaucoup nous
avons le bit coin qui monte lui aussi
beaucoup avec l'ensemble des autres
crypto monnaie et il y a un problème
aussi d'inégalités sociales parce qu'on
sait très bien que les personnes qui
possèdent des titres boursiers c'est
grosso modo le 1 pour cent le plus riche
au mieux le d pour cent le plus riche de
la population donc ce sont eux qui
bénéficient d'une certaine manière de
ces hausses de taux le reste de la
population n'en bénéficient pas et par
contre subi une inflation et puis il ya
un troisième pointe on voit aujourd'hui
et ça a été très clair par exemple dans
l'allocution café emmanuel macron le 9
novembre on voit qu'on est en train de
s'orienter vers une politique
d'investissement extrêmement important
et d'une certaine manière cette
politique est bien elle va nécessiter
des engagements de l'état de plus en
plus important encore il faut entendre
ce qu'elle dit emmanuel macron le marché
ne peut pas tout l'état va devoir
intervenir et donc les banques centrales
vont devoir s'adapter à cette nouvelle
situation et de sous-produits l'a
élaboré une nouvelle stratégie mais le
faire sans casser la croissance actuelle
et c'est peut-être ça le principal défi
qu'elles ont devant l'autel merci
beaucoup à vous jacques sapir pour cette
analyse merci à vous et à la semaine
prochaine merci beaucoup c'est la fin de
cette émission rendez-vous donc lundi
prochain 20 heures pour une prochaine
émission ça sera bien sûr avec un
stéphanie de mu rues d'ici là n'oubliez
pas de réagir de commenter de poser vos
questions sur le télégramme verte et
france un prochain point sur l'actualité
ce sera dans une trentaine à 2 minutes
très bonne soirée à vous sur rtl
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]